woman allegedly breastfeeds cat on delta
airlines okay
yeah by the way this is not a satire
story
this is not i thought
i thought we agreed not to uh pat i
thought we agreed not to cover the
madonna story
fyi this is a newsweek story yeah this
is not onion this is not like babylon
beat this is newsweek credible newspaper
woman on recent delta airlines flight
allegedly began breastfeeding her cat
a pet mid-flight and refused to stop
after getting caught the image
circulating online describes by the way
can you pull up this image
the supposed event in what appears to be
a screen capture of a message sent u.s
aircraft communications addressing the
reporting system which pilots used to
transmit short text-based messages to
the ground the message reports that a
passenger in c-13a's breastfeeding cabin
will not put cat back in carrier in
response to a request from a flight
attendant the message asks that the
situation be addressed by the airline's
retco team upon landing delta describes
a members of the team as elite airport
customer service experts who are
specially trained to handle on-the-stop
customer issues
now how do you train this how do you say
well guys if you ever let me explain how
that works
how do you trade this
let me take it over from here buddy how
do you train this
since you
uh this is the type of lady that i meet
at the cat conference that i go to when
i was in
find this girl by the way and there's
somebody find this girl all i want to
say she was in 13 a i wish i was in 13 b
we would have we would have said we
would throw some covers
some emotional moments it would have
been it would have been a wonderful
moment
this lady is a hero and she's being
scorned and shamed in public when she's
just trying to feed her damn cats
well whoever she lives
not long enough
[Laughter]
so there's your story you wanted it we
covered it thank you are you happy yeah
now let's cover lebron
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you